hikaru nakamura's five most amazing queen
sacrifices this deserved a blazer that's how
good the examples are how stunning they are how
amazing they are see if you can spot knackers
moves and make sure you like and subscribe
to this channel this first example is maybe
his most famous example he's got the black
pieces against strong grand master chrysenko
and after the move d takes c4 kazrenko played
knight to c6 now this has the idea that after
rook takes c6 white plays bishop takes f6 and
this is where we start the queen is attacked and
white is trying to take the bishop on e7
what stunning idea did hikaru find here
and how did he follow up see if you can analyze as
deeply as the naka monster did well he now played
boom queen takes f2 oh la la la look at that for
a stunning move and after king takes f2 the bishop
moves into c5 with check and the king hunt now
starts white moved his king up to f3 other options
are no better for example if he tries blocking
it the bishop can simply take that rook and if
the king comes to this square we can keep taking
things with check and now we're going to win the
white queen and this leads to a winning position
had the king come back to f1 look at the power of
those assassins cheekily pointing at the white
king and with the move c3 rookie 2 is the only
way to stop that check in a decent way but now
a brilliant move c2 what a stunning idea there
so we go back to the game the king came walking
to its death and hikari said okay time to kill
rook to f6 check king g4 another piece
comes flying into the action knight to e5
check and this position is very bad all of
black's remaining pieces are trapping that king
out in the open like no man's land the king
is about to be taken down the king steps to g5
and now rook g6 king h5 and here a very
nice move f6 this threatens rook h6 which
is checkmate because we're covering the g5 square
and that white king is clearly in too much danger
white tried rook takes e5 but now another black
rook came in the check and after king h4 the next
move forced resignation bishop to c8 i love these
quiet moves that hikaru played here in the middle
of the storm did anyone see all the way up to this
position that's kind of how far you need to see
if you want to be hikaru's strength and with this
move rook h6 and other ideas are really not going
to be stopped here so white reside this next
one was taken from the speed chest challenge on
chess.com and we have the very talented brilliant
player aronian with the white pieces against
hikaru and it's only a five minute game making
the next couple of moves even that more stunning
now bishop e7 was aronian's idea to keep attacking
the black king and it does look like the black
king is under some damage danger here but look how
hikaru turns the position around queen takes e7
oh yeah aronian you're not attacking
me i'm gonna have some fun against you
yeah boy and now after knight takes e7 king takes
e7 well black has given up the queen but as we're
going to shortly see is the white king which is in
a lot of danger with stuff like rook g8 being the
immediate threat the game continued queen takes
b7 and now just king d7 making sure the white king
the white king is still weak and the white queen
can't get in the position queen takes a6 pawn
takes c3 opening the bishop and threatening
bishop here check queen b5 and now the king
is surprisingly safe on this square and after
bishop to b6 the rook is going to come in this way
queen to e2 stopping that but now my favorite
move this whole combination rook a4 black finds
a way to bring the rook over towards white's
king and now the pressure is just too much
queen to g2 and here knight g4 check that
knight now defending and after king h1
knight to e3 and white tri queen to c6 but rook h3
check is completely winning as we're going to see
the rooks coming over here next move as well as
other things so aronian resigned a great example
of turning defense into attack something you guys
should always try to strive for the initiative in
this next example we jump back to 1999 and little
hikaru was still very dangerous he's playing the
wax man here and it's white to play how did he
break through defenses and remember you can use
that pause button queen 2h5 check just imagine
sliding that move on to the board how satisfying
it would be and this really has the main aim of
releasing the bishop on d3 that bishop becomes
extremely strong for example if the queen is
captured e5 check and now the only move is f5 but
after knight takes f5 black really has no defense
the bishop is now threatened to release itself
rook g7 is another threat and if you try to
get rid of the knight just bishop takes their
fighters check mate a lovely move black tried
king g8 but after queen g6 it's clear to see
that white is completely winning great play from
hikaru yet again now this is boris gelfand with
the white pieces against hikaru at black and i
have looked at this position before in my series
on the king's indian defense if you're a premium
member on chess.com you can view that series
now here hikaru's queen has been on
pre for a number of moves he doesn't
actually get the chance to sacrifice it but rather
than now moving the queen he plays bishop h3
and this is a beautiful move because if the
queen is captured here this is czech mate
and the fireworks continue white plays bishop
to f1 covering that square and can you now see
what hikaru played i love this move one of
my favorite ever hikaru moves queen to d3
and yes i know i've looked at this before
but i had to include it again it's just so
beautiful the idea is again if the queen is
taken g2 is free and if the bishop is taken
we can come into f3 and then g2 with checkmate
and in this position really white has no defense
he tried knight takes e5 but now the queen has
again left on pre with bishop takes f1 bishop g2
to fret and eventually hikaru just takes a knight
on c3 a lovely sort of series of moves there just
leaving that queen to be captured but it can never
be captured due to the checkmate frets beautiful
those of you with a great memory may just recall
how magnus carlsen defeated sergey karjakin
with what's been called the best ever checkmate in
the last game last move of the world championships
but in actual fact the sequence and the pattern
that magnus used was used first by hikaru and
in this game played well before that world
championships it's now hikaru to move he plays
rook g1 check and after king to a2 can you see the
stunning move that forced resignation immediately
and if you know that pattern and chess is all
about patterns so the more patterns you learn the
better you get what move now can you see remember
the pattern in the in the game can you see it
queen takes a free check and i love this move
because whatever happens rook a1 is gonna be
checkmate next move exactly the same sort of
sequence we saw but hikaru got it in first
well done hikaru so which of those five examples
was your favorite queen sacrifice do leave your
comments below please make sure you like and
subscribe to this video there's many other
videos in this series where you can look at
stunning moves stunning ideas to hopefully
improve your play i'll be back with more
videos soon goodbye and cheers for now